Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Marcus, Sarah, Priya. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
I know we locked the staggered rollout order on July 14th. I'm reopening it, and I want to be explicit about why up front: District Two just pulled out.
That's genuinely new information, not me relitigating a decision I lost.
Agreed it's worth reopening — the whole sequence assumed three districts. The premise changed, so the plan should.
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
Okay, works for me.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Makes sense to me.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Makes sense.
This is the healthy kind of reopen, and I want to name that so we don't confuse it with the license situation last quarter. New facts, not the same argument replayed. What's the new order?
Got it.
With two districts, put the least-TK one first as we agreed, and I fold District Three's onboarding forward a week.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the backend capability model and the provenance schema anyway.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That's fair.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Makes sense to me.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Makes sense to me.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Makes sense to me.
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Right, that's what I meant.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Hang on, let me pull that doc up on my end. One sec.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Okay, works for me.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Makes sense to me.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Right, that's what I meant.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Let's confirm in the channel.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
How does this interact with the browse and install front end, if at all?
Sure, I can own that.
Sure — one sec.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the CARE governance framework.
Let me park that and come back to it.
Let me share my screen so we're all looking at the same thing.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Right, that's what I meant.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Agreed, let's capture it.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Makes sense to me.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let's confirm in the channel.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
That's fair.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Good point — let's do that.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the browse and install front end.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the browse and install front end anyway.
Okay, works for me.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
That's fair.
Yeah, exactly.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
How does this interact with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, if at all?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's confirm in the channel.
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
How does this interact with the browse and install front end, if at all?
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, exactly.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay, works for me.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Yeah, exactly.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Just flagging that this touches the browse and install front end, so loop me in when it firms up.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
That's fair.
Good. New order set. And per our reopening bar, I'm noting in the ADR that this reopen was justified by District Two dropping — so if anyone looks later, the trigger is on the record.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the backend capability model and the provenance schema.
Okay, works for me.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Good point — let's do that.
Right, right.
Exactly right. Reopening on new information is commitment working, not commitment failing.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay, yeah.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the backend capability model and the provenance schema?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the the browse and install front end side, or is that covered?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Marcus has the follow-up on the backend capability model and the provenance schema — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.